this was the midsummer night when Whaley
bridge was on the brink there reservoir
wall had been cut open by the torrents
and nobody knew how long the clay
beneath it would hold it was time
critical we were told the dam was going
to go if nothing was done and we worried
to help
there were several volunteers to go down
in fact almost everybody volunteered but
it was the work in a high esteem that
could go down onto the wall itself but
because of the risk I was the one that
went on to the dam top one man working
on a wall that could give way at any
moment Jeff laid down over 300 sandbags
to protect the damaged section the town
is just there and there's a hell of a
lot of water just there the town
wouldn't have been there it's you know
that that was the way it was told
towards the town wouldn't have been
there they've managed to get almost
everyone out of the middle of Whaley
Bridge
Chief Inspector Paul Markham was about
to take over the operation overnight
when I came on the information I was
given that if we do nothing then that
dam will go there was six times as much
water coming into the dam than we were
getting out there was well over a
billion litres up against a crumbling
dam wall and then at 9:30 p.m. the team
shouted at Jeff get off the bridge
there's there was a real gush of water
came out so whether it's a block
somewhere inside but it came bursting
out so everybody had to evacuate you
know you think potentially you were
gonna when they the water came out from
underneath but that could have been the
same for any one of us because of it
they were all volunteer the thinking was
it was that was the start of the dam
going and fortunately it wasn't the RAF
then came in the water was pumped out
and that's how this town home to 6,000
people was saved now drive through way
to bridge quite regularly go through
that on the train and you look at it and
you think you know what we did a good
job here we did a good job you wouldn't
expect Jeff to think of himself as a
hero and he doesn't he was just one of
many here who did what he could Tom
Parmenter Sky News Derbyshire